nothing but net
up up and away web never wish for a
death wish
hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and it's John over here so today we're
gonna watch the trailer number dos for
the highly anticipated never had a
backlash once of death wish never wish
for a death wish a death wish always
comes true and you'll love it love it Oh
death wish is being remade with Bruce
Willis from director Eli Roth who did
not know
it's about five I told you I love you
yes told me like taken take you please
come down here
[Music]
it's paradise on this happen you can't
go in there
[Music]
I'm sorry dr. Z nothing yet
so there's nothing that I could do is
that what you're saying have faith had
faith work out for them
good question wants to protect what's
his
[Music]
he has to do it for himself
[Music]
nice
my wife
is going to take
[Music]
we'll never wish for a Oh death wish
always comes true still did that trailer
voice that guy who's really trying to
sell you the movie look I'm gonna
sandwich bag my opinions here sandwich
bag meaning what a lot of youtubers do
start off positive then you give your
criticisms then you sandwich it and you
know with another positive thing on
there but I'm gonna give you a warning
there's some chips on the side for you
you might want to down this a little
Pepsi while you're at it I'm probably
gonna feel more of the negatives that I
am the positive I'll admit when I saw
the first trailer yes I think I'm just
so opposite about the way a lot of
people sometimes feel when I saw the
first show that had the I think it was
ac/dc music and it was rocking out he's
just killing guys I was actually on
board for it I was like that looks
pretty cool than me I'm down with this
I'm like I know it looks completely
totally different than the OG Death Wish
which has a much more serious vibe about
it more realistic arguably yeah when
they come from that different time we're
like street punks were just so wild in
their portrayal yeah like the original
Death Wish films have like a camp about
them I feel like but there is assert
that God way more campy as they
progressed oh yeah yeah as they would
but they are dated you know oh
absolutely
okay so what do I like about this
trailer I've completely ruined the whole
sandwich thing by
[Music]
[Laughter]
but everything just by me saying I'm
gonna feel more than anything what are
some of the positives there gee I feel
like this could be Eli Roth enjoyable
Eli Roth is such a gonna be entertaining
see I don't know about that because I
often have that headspace with Eli Roth
films I've seen a wider Eli Roth films
surprisingly I think I've seen them all
every time I see it trailer even if it
looks like a bad movie I sell myself but
it's probably gonna at least be fun and
entertaining and nine times out of ten
I'm just intensely annoyed that's the
one thing that this trailer doesn't hint
at that it's gonna be annoying
performances you got the guy from
Breaking Bad Dean Norris I think is his
name you got Bruce Willis who if he's
awake for a film he does all right yeah
the performances don't look
overbearingly annoying at all which is
very antithesis to a lot of Eli Roth
movies at least from this looks like he
kind of showed up oh yeah I mean I feel
like he's aware it's a remake but at the
same time I'd be aware it's Eli Roth and
this is a role that he's kind of sick of
doing there could be that because the
role the performance looks like he
showed up and good for a trailer at the
same time I'm a little concerned because
I'm thinking to myself that he doesn't
really look like he has that much
emotion at all in this trailer yeah
beyond cool calm Bruce Willis yeah the
reason I was on board for the first
trailer was because it looked like it
was just having a fun time with its
premise here's why I don't like this
trailer is because all the heavy stuff
doesn't feel heavy it just feels corny
it feels cheesy all this stuff with him
getting like crazy-ass guns taking on
the gangs when I'm like this guy's a
doctor
Oh what is the I don't remember anything
about the og death which like what his
profession was I'm wondering to myself
like wait a minute you're going for this
like serious tone where I'm supposed to
buy this in a real way but yet you're
presenting stuff to me that just seemed
stupid and ridiculous when you're
playing like ac/dc music and he's like
smashing people's faces with a car but
works when it sells that jack-jack yeah
this just kinda got me totally confused
on what this movie's gonna try to be
like nowadays they've started to do this
with certain movies where they'll pitch
it in one flavor and then they'll come
back and just pitch it in a different
flavor and not really elaborate on what
the movie is supposed to be this movie
kind of has the same stuff in it in the
post Punisher world this is starting to
feel a little stale and I feel bad for
them I guess it's all too familiar it's
just way too familiar to punish and it
looks like there's not but even the
Punisher plotline isn't exactly 100
percent unique it's the execution in the
character study that makes it unique and
the Punisher borrows from Death Wish
anyways there's anything really unique
to offer though I guess the one thing I
can look forward to is Eli Roth is known
to not hold back on violence and this is
an action movie not a psychological
wannabe thriller or a wannabe horror
movie from PLI Roth it is an action
movie so I'm thinking maybe with some of
the things that can often get on my
nerves about Eli Roth this would be fine
ended genre of this movie getting like
ridiculous violence in I hope we get a
red band trailer I think if we get some
crazy violence in an action movie like
that will now make up for a lot for me
and if the tone is that of an Eli Roth
movie it could work yeah this tone I
don't like I don't like this tone it but
if it's that of an Eli Roth film which
is cheesy and corny and you don't really
take it that serious then it's your and
you know pretty gooeys yeah for whatever
it is I mean there are some of the early
moments of this trailer hinted that
there would be at least a good amount of
tension when crime is taking with that
whole thing with his wife at the
beginning was you know translated like a
horror movie and I feel like he could
bring that vibe because you know again
those original Deathwish movies like the
actual street punk characters are like
wild and kind of scary yes so like
bringing that element to the crime stuff
here could be pretty cool it could be
cool and in terms of an updated remake
the the whole thing with like I mean
this is what you do with all updated
remakes is you include YouTube there's a
video that's gonna play this person
talking
on the radio yeah but I actually like
that element I'm interested to see the
vigilante portrayal that that they have
going on in this movie right now this is
not so much an issue with the film it's
an issue with the marketing is how it is
about this but yeah a lot of the time I
can tell what a film will be like based
off its marketing and if the consistent
trailers are consistent here the did we
got two very different trailers seems
like there's a lot of backlash for the
first trailer and now we got this
trailer I'm sitting back going no idea
what this film is actually gonna be like
and because they're gonna rework parts
yeah I mean to be a different tone now
because they did push the release date
on it too it'd be cool if this movie was
cool I'm not entirely
I'm not sold on it I'll wait for the 45
percent on Rotten Tomatoes gets about 30
you're like whoa this must be an
approved yeah well yeah I wonder now I'm
like can this be to Eli Roth
this is a recognizable property I'm sure
there's somebody around to be like hang
on a minute yo go too far out yeah well
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
melih get notified every time one of our
videos is up and you could download and
follow us on the stardust app link in
the description box check out our
patreon it's like a second youtube
channel trying to get to 100 patrons
right now I'm not trying but I figured
you got to entice you in some way to
check it out come on over come on over
baby